months and 18 days that was a draw but
magnus at some point outplaying kasparov
in that game do you know how old avimani
mishra is today the exact same
almost he is only three days younger
than magnus was at that time i guess
what opening it is i was gonna say
it's bad news you know what was the
highest scoring um opening
this one the slime was the slouch
no one's told him about the statistics
maybe we should have released it before
to all the players and gone here you go
and uh magnus meanwhile he's chosen a
kind of rare branch of the slav
white has temporarily temporarily given
up a pawn but white is about to get the
bishop pair so white's knight has gone
to the edge of the board and is going to
take off the black light square bishop
and expert yesterday getting some great
positions out of the opening mishra so
i'm sure he knows what he's doing
despite the stats that we saw of the
slav defense and okay current position
black is a pawn up but black has two
sets of double pawns on the c file and
the f file i'm balancing the situation
seems to be a good choice because if you
play if you play a standard position
against magnus you're probably going to
get outplayed so at least he's got some
sort of uh strange structure and we see
magnus has now
won the pawn back uh but black has very
good control of central squares with his
knights coming into those squares
white's light squared bishop again it's
under attack by one of the black knights
so that white light square bishop is
going to take a step back
and magnus playing the most popular move
in my database and uh well i'd be mind
you now playing something that's second
choice in fact
sam of course uh producing a chessable
course on the semi-slav know where the
slav can go wrong for black babies
basically yeah i mean it's a very solid
opening for black it's often a part of
players repertoires when they're quite
young and i think you know what just
they're waiting well now he's played f3
so that's quite interesting yeah that's
a great point uh carl there if white
does castle i think this is a huge
practical mistake because i mean if i
were playing simon for example he would
not hesitate he would throw harry the
age pawn down the board try and open up
this black rook uh towards the white
king and if black gets one more move
throws this ball forward again then it's
exactly what you mentioned there this
white pawn is what we call a hook it
kind of helps black to even open the
position that pawn is coming forward and
uh it's going to cause a lot of
well i would say worries on the right
side and uh abi manu kind of playing a
little bit calmer he steps back with the
bishop still this this kind of dilemma
remains white's gonna kind of keep you
guessing which side you're going on and
okay magnus does play this exact move
very logical maybe at some point hinting
that he's gonna push forward in the
center but
how does this bishop move help i don't
really understand a lot of people his
age he was quite a lot younger than me
when i was playing them they get quite
scared you know because i'd play quite
quickly and you could just tell they
gave you far too much respect and i
remember playing gwen and uh i mean
that's
takes a lot of uh skill and courage
and finally we have harry moving two
squares up the board and
the grandmaster just go let's play kid
and that was it
he was like oh no
50 moves
yeah the repetitions the three move
repetitions
that is kind of a draw agreement though
isn't it it's always ends up king versus
king or it ends up in a repetition of
moves so why have the draw offers anyway
um because i was actually told the
reverse by a very strong ground masters
it's actually much easier to defend
yes it feels a bit inconsistent some of
his play i like black's last move just
tucking the king away closer to the
corner just good general kind of chest
wisdom if you castle on the long side
just spend an extra move pushing your
king as close to the corner of the board
as possible it's just safer there
but
somehow it just feels a bit slow but it
just seems um a little bit strange and
this is okay things are going to
certainly change now after magnus
pushing aggressively in center but why
play your harold pawn why then play in
the middle and then play on the other
side and then you know you're kind of
just not really doing anything
consistent here that's exactly what
magnus has done throughout his career
he's dominated games it's a bit like in
sport controlling possession not
allowing your opponent any chances and
it's rare for a kind of a weaker team to
do that um and yeah in chess
at least mishra yesterday he showed he
can dominate you generally have an
advantage because you're more flexible
when you use that center and that's
that's where magnus's main advantage
either for uh is is in this position and
the two bishops of course
yeah and we're just sliding away with
the white queen out of the island of the
black crook so now for example if we see
a trade of knights this is what we call
the ultimate center
oh yeah just supporting everything
replacing pawns with other pawns you put
up the perfect opening for white and the
pawns is in that exact position yeah um
as i say that i'm not sure which way
magnus will take back you know he's
taking the bishop it also has a lot to
say for it but yeah either way the ideal
center to me like beginner level this
looks so good for white
and it is it is good and it's just a sim
simply an easier position for white they
also because white controls the center
have the potential just to go to the
right go to the left they have that
flexibility and uh yeah that's a bit of
a analogy
[Laughter]
there is a point here about about chess
about knowing when to hold and when to
push it's really important in a general
sense because
many people myself included have lost
games that we could easily have held if
we just waited sit back wait to move no
we have to go for it don't we too
compulsive know when to wait know when
to go inspired by paul morphy i'll be
monie mishra maybe but uh struggling in
this game wow there's been a few changes
actually okay in this position because
abby manuel you know he didn't sit and
wait he was like well let me challenge
the white pawn center and i was a little
bit surprised to see magnus actually
capture that pawn those pawns look weak
on the right side
but at the same time they have the
potential to generate some dynamic play
and uh at least the black knight is no
longer a dead piece black's knight can
jump into the center of the board to the
d5 square later um it does have
potential
if you can okay first he trades rooks is
the intention now uh next move to jump
into the middle of the board with the
black knight interesting and well abe
monument he has ticked down two three
minutes on the clock and he takes it
with a bishop retreating a bishop to the
first rank is not such a bad thing
um okay
mishra he knew one of his pawns was
doomed so he threw it forward and now
two harry is a better than one right
simon white has two h pawns that's what
they say i think the main point here is
that's a pass pawn so in the ending it
could become a queen because there's
nothing obstructing it
black pushes his past pawn forward he's
created a passport of his own porn
especially a past one now white has a
permanent blockade on the light squares
that's true that's very true yeah i
think both kings are pretty safe right
now white's king potentially a bit
vulnerable but it can just shuffle off
into the corner if it really needs to
first mishra trying to activate his
knight
stockfish
a lot of people do that's true
look at that intense look i mean that
that's frightening that that's that's
really really off-putty yeah i'm sure he
doesn't mean it but he just has that
fixed glaze yeah taking some prisoners
i'm taking no prisoners okay no
christmas yeah
should i say then happy jubilee day is
it how do you it's it's in june oh okay
so it's not yet it's like preparations
though yeah we'll remember yeah all
right we do have some moves and magnus
did decide which way to go with his
bishop yeah and i really like what
mishra has done on the last move at
least i think it was a very necessary um
decision to jump in with the black
knight and there has been a trade so
let's check out what's happening okay
magnus not getting greedy and allowing a
pawn to survive so if we backtrack just
one move uh we see that in this position
black's knight yes it's on a great
outpost but it's not really affecting
play you need to get rid of white's
bishop pair that is the number one
priority the longer the game goes on the
more powerful they'll become so still
roughly in the balance mishra is
fighting back after a very difficult
position because i'm david 15 seconds is
that right wow okay i mean let's go back
to the players actually because the
clock is gonna play a big big factor i
think you move it two squares it's
defended by the bishop and here it goes
yeah running so strong that pawn and it
could okay you've got to try to guard it
with the bishop the bishop does control
the queening square of white's pawn but
the bishop is also very loose there it's
in a pin there could be some nasty
tactics like queen check and everything
it gets traded off so
if black just takes the time out pushes
a pawn uh okay he pushes this pawn
that's important but then check as simon
says yeah and then very strong position
as ivanka mentions this is
okay it has just happened queen takes
pawn is not a blunder it's not a mouse
slip if the white queen is taken then
white can recapture the black queen and
this rook now cannot actually go and
grab the white rook because it has to
keep an eye on this corner square it has
to keep an eye on the white pawn okay
the queen trade is about to happen
measure down to five seconds though
and okay that was a check black's queen
blocked
block off black's rook okay the white
bishop though is gonna act as the
blockader it's gonna go up to g8 and
look at this this is gonna lock in that
black rook into the corner
i love it does well i'd be tempted to
play rook takes bishop here to show off
but
i don't know this move is
very visual i like these visual little
things where the rook is trapped and
we've been talking about chess and
prisons that black rook is a prisoner
now right it can never get out and you
can just look at the rest of the board
count the rest of the pieces he's played
this move this this this looked like a
very pretty way of winning with the
white king running in eventually in the
ending yeah so white's actually down on
material right now but white is
completely winning because that black
rook is caged in
and yeah the black pawn in the middle is
going to drop sooner or later
like you're kind of saying it's like
they don't exist
so that is true
it certainly is it's actually better
than not existing for white because that
white bishop takes away some squares
from the black king white's bishop
actually plays an active part black's
rook is a passive actually having the
extra the extra h pawn helps a lot here
because you can uh you can use that to
save time at the right case and black's
probably going to run out of moves as
we're going to reach a position already
that's what uh that's called zugzwang
that means any move black makes will
worsen his own position and look at the
black king it's completely stuck
defending black's pawn in the middle of
the board sooner or later black's
running out of moves there's nothing
else to do black's king is going to have
to give way and white will just use his
king take the black horn in the center
and
start darting towards the black rook but
does he need to take that black pawn
before he starts running forwards yes
he'll wait until black runs out of moves
he'll take that black pawn in the center
and then the white king will go
towards that black rogue it's game over
there we go
had to move
and misha is trying to adopt a formation
we call the opposition where black's
king blocks off white's king from moving
forward but again as simon said white
can wait sooner or later with this pawn
that is a very useful pawn we talked
about
those two harry potters this one is
actually doing the winning uh and is it
now suggs wang already or are we going
to be it will be in the next move
so
any move that abby manu makes will just
worsen his position he would just
actually like just to go pass yeah
unfortunately you can't do that in jazz
and uh yeah i think we'll see a result
any moment just uh we'll explain it
maybe in more detail a bit later but the
black king is going to have to give way
no matter which way the black king goes
the white king will go the opposite way
and trader pawns will not help black
here we go the white king is coming in
now
and yeah
max king
unable to help
it's getting close then i guess a win
for magnus carlsen striking back after
losing to prague in
round five
mishra giving it a good go but of course
facing the world champion
it will be hard for a 13 year old
and we saw a quick flurry of moves there
white's king did grab the remaining
black pawn
and it's not only one porn that black
has to deal with now all of those white
pawns are pushing forward
and you can tell on the body language
magnus knows it's winning and mishra
gives up
it's over a win for magnus carlsen
striking back
winning against the youngest grand
master in history it's a long and
interesting game